horror che era da un po che non ne
facevo per la mia gioia ma non per la
vostra visto che ogni volta che passa
pina settimana dove non faccio un horror
mica che non tutte le balle allora
facciamo noi va bene gli faccio da
cinque anni ormai ciò l'infarto a
momenti quindi non problemi yerli deve
l'op mentre damon tutti fanno st
premessa della serie se il gioco va
fatto cagare o è una demo è quindi non
state così critici se mi fa cagare lo
dico però non l'ho pagato quindi è già
una cosa positiva
vedi faccia schifo il gioco ci sono le
cimici parte ste cagate qua il gioco o
non mi sono mosso già successe troppe
cose nella pentola che è caduta una
porta che si è chiusa e c'è un quadro
del mio nonno siamo in una casa
abbandonata ovviamente non si capisce
come ci siamo arrivati però è una demo
quindi siamo buoni ma io ci ho ripensato
guarda quasi quasi vado nel corridoio
che me frega di andare qua non è
corridoio come vandone persone normali
no e questa è chiusa
spuntata in armadio tante cose così in
fretta devono solo le polaroid
mi chiamo neuro a polaroid la faccio
luca si prende tutte questo soldi tab
inventory 10 polaroid 10 euro regalati
dovremmo tornare in teoria per cui è
comparso un armadio senese jack nobile
che mi fa le magie che è successo non
vorrei togliere il telo pro togliamo su
amazon questo 250 euro sta fare quindi
sarà non amazon prime che mi hanno
inviato in tre secondi sto coso bello mi
piace fatto bene legno pregiato possiamo
dare a ma devo andare di qua alla fine
devo andare di qua comunque quindi
spiegato voce una chiave rega studia
studia vedi anche le chiavi nei
videogiochi ti ricordano che devi
studiare non devo guardarmi video che
sono in casa pure le chiavi vabbè ma di
qua
tanto c'è qualcosa che non riesco a
vedere perché anzi meno male che non
avendo con controllata una chiave
andiamo ad aprire la porta che l'unica
porta che rim che accusano del corridoio
madonna che ma che sto dentro un frigo
ci sta pure bottiglie michea scricchiola
tutto cadono le pentole le bottiglie
richiesto veramente un frigo sta a casa
vabbè porta la chiave non rompete le
balle mondadori inserire st chiave
esclusione a ok si apriva trascinandoti
un'amnesia alle polaroid subito e un
tizio quello
allora potrò navi che mi sembra un tizio
di spalle che ansia
ciao e vabbè nome non mi dice che ci
sono le lettere dei profughi grande uomo
vedi anche lui ai risvolti ni però lui
ha un motivo per averci dice il mare
dietro quindi ci sta simpatico
va bene sale ad uno speciale dietro
quadro simpatico no marietta ora gun tg5
creiamo dei contenuti in questo momento
su youtube ma siamo capaci di grandi
anche su altre piattaforme
non capisco l'inglese perché lo so ai
livelli di renzi quindi non li ascolta
io andrei avanti se è possibile perché
tanto c'è una porta formato mignon di
centraco dentro lo mette bizet
vorrebbero lloyd le polaroid e prendo
sempre me le foto sempre negato se si
potesse entrare qua dentro sarebbe epico
però non ci penso neanche se mi abbasso
parte che chiuso
esce un codice la madonna c'è un pacco
però qualche non aveva previsto una e
luca luca e molliccio
da mamma papà luca la parola abbiamo
tutto regal altro che amazon
ora posso fare le foto posso fare buona
noi va bene facciamo una parola è un
euro polaroid e regala quindi ogni foto
neuro casino se sta roba
oh mio dio mi ricordo ancora quanto mi
ha fatto male indossarlo perché ha
indossato sta roba
cioè dei gusti che minchia il suo micio
si metterebbe le mani nei capelli
no no scherzavo avere a che proviamo
riuscire in corridoio che ci sono non si
può uscire in corridoio perché si è
chiusa la porta fantastico mi piace
questo gioco non facciamo fare però
entrato a ok la modalità polaroid
capisco raga ma che non vedo niente sto
facendo la polaroid solo per vedere gli
per vedere al buio devo farle polaroid
raga ma stiamo scherzando
sicché triste che vado fotografare per
vedere perché se no non vedo praga il
jump square ea momenti ve lo dico io
66 da una tua madre morta che è successo
che è il lampadario mi sembra un
palloncino quello di minchia che kakà
bassa andiamo alla fine del corridoio
no basta amazon aveva già preso due cose
no recava veramente economista veramente
distruggendo l'anima ma magari non c'è
niente dove faccia andare a prenderlo
qualcosa mi scusi basta ai piani gli
orologi farci niente
avevano male ma non c'è spazio inutile
occupato in casa che sta roba scritta
che la foto del tizio culo gnocco come
prima eccolo fede quant'è bello bello
bello quest'uomo con la metto press cosa
è che ti serve scusa a dove mettete il
chiodino che ti serve di aldo spiegami
chiorino per attaccarlo ma perché dovrei
attaccare un quadro li spiega ancora il
problema mio
basta inviarne nn che il nervi ma che me
ne fa ma poi scusa o alcol e chiodino
non sono che un uomo fatto a trovarlo ma
l'ho trovato bene
basta e verità
[Musica]
ok va bene e io c'ho il mio chiodino
cerchiamo occhiolino eccolo qua c o
chiudo nepi che chiudiamo ammazzare
ok e adesso perfetto top
l'architetto sono diventato adesso è
meglio che diventò make up artists
perché qui è un casino lo si fanno
affatto al quadro maxi brutto si è rotto
pure del vetro thunar o tu sei brutto ma
che cazzo ne addita pure ma che problemi
ci hai è spuntata una porta va bene a
stavi indicando la porta non me va bene
selezionare l'oggetto da usare ma spero
funzioni di mola chiave alla chiave non
era per l'altra porterà per questa va
bene a si apre all'interno simpatico sto
gioco
capisco tutto è caduta una pentola per
ora figo però era una demo c'e nel senso
era molto slim come cosa c'è la faccenda
abbastanza c'è giocato a demo più lunghe
per carità di dio però accorto molto
corto moltissimo fatti sta allungando
con la frase con l'altro finale del
video se non riesce veramente corto
corto è che dobbiamo arrivare a dieci
minuti che monetizzati più adatta bene a
scuola come va tutto a posto
yo yo bene mi sveglio la mattina faccio
store
pensate che vita di merda prendo quadri
nel tempo libero quindi se vi serve uno
che smanetta che martelli sui muri
possibilmente quadri che ci siano di
persone belle tipo ma non come il tipo
di prima che sembra un po pietro a
proposito io nella mia vita ho scroccato
sempre un sacco di polaroid alla gente
perché ci anno fa
polaroid macchinette e io le usano mi
chiama ogni volta che la [ __ ] una
lista o fottendo un euro e non lo sapevo
mi chiama de sarlo sarei miliardaria
questo la se avessi tenuto tutte le
polaroid che ho sprecato
siamo arrivati a 10 minuti ai ragazzi
padre fa niente per la monetizzazione
anche oggi monetizza domani però che i
video vi sia piaciuto ragazzi consenso
che certamente mi piace anche questo è
il mio da letizia le cose distinte e mi
raccomando usate le polaroid per
fotografare la gente bella portate lei
mi era doni e ci vediamo al prossimo
vita da ragazzi
[Musica]